[Musique]
le département c'est aussi et surtout
des agents impliqués est réparti sur
tout il après une première session à
villèle c'est sur le site des berges de
la rivière des roches à bras panon que
les agents du nord et de l'est ce sont
venus assister aux voeux traditionnels
du président le directeur général des
services nous rappelle les points clés
ressorti de la démarche qualité de vie
au travail entamé par la collectivité
le premier de renforcer l'écouté et la
solidarité de la part bien évidemment de
l'encadrement mais aussi surtout entre
agents deuxième axe s'était renforcé la
qualité de nos actions peut toujours
progresser qu'il s'agisse d'un service
en interne au département ou surtout de
service au profit de nos différents
publics et enfin renforcer le rôle
d'impulsion et de coordination du
conseil départemental de la réunion je
rappelle on ne dit pas assez souvent que
c'est la première collectivité de l'île
par les effectifs et par le budget
agents techniques et administratifs
ils étaient plus de 500 agents à avoir
fait le déplacement mais pour la
collectivité 2018 a été aussi marquée
par un important travail avec les
communes à travers le pacte de
solidarité territoriale comme le
rappelle cyrille melchior
mes remerciements alors qu'il faut
maintenant ses liens entre les
différentes et le département
j'évolue et maintenant l'action sociale
et je sais que dans nos territoires
quels besoins
les acteurs les légumes les pmi les
arrondissements
nous avons des acteurs et personnel qui
travaille en lien avec les communes fois
justement renforcer la cohésion sociale
mais surtout renforcer l'efficacité de
nos mesures sociales
avec plus de 5000 agents territoriaux
la collectivité se mobilise au quotidien
auprès des familles réunionnaises
[Musique]